In this video we'll use
hierarchical clustering
to cluster the movies in the
movie lens data set by genre.
After we make our
clusters, we'll
see how they can be used
to make recommendations.
There are two steps to
hierarchical clustering.
First we have to compute the
distances between all data
points.
And then we need to
cluster the points.
To compute the distances we
can use the dist function.
We only want a cluster
movies on the genre variable,
not on the title variable, so
we'll cluster on columns two
through 20.
So let's call the
output distances,
and we'll use the dist function,
where the first argument is
moviesmovies[2:20], this is what
we want to cluster on.
And the second argument
is method="euclidean",
meaning that we want to
use euclidean distance.
Now let's cluster our movies
using the hclust function
for hierarchical clustering.
We'll call the
output clusterMovies,
and use hclust where the
first argument is distances,
the output of the dist function.
And the second argument
is method="ward".
The ward method cares about the
distance between clusters using
centroid distance, and
also the variance in each
of the clusters.
Now let's plot the dendrogram
of our clustering algorithm
by typing plot, and then in
parentheses clusterMovies.
This dendrogram might
look a little strange.
We have all this black
along the bottom.
Remember that the
dendrogram lists
all of that data points
along the bottom.
But when there are
over 1,000 data points
it's impossible to read.
We'll see later how to assign
our clusters to groups so
that we can analyze which data
points are in which cluster.
So looking at this
dendrogram, how many clusters
would you pick?
It looks like maybe
three or four clusters
would be a good choice
according to the dendrogram.
But let's keep our
application in mind, too.
We probably want more than two,
three, or even four clusters
of movies to make
recommendations to users.
It looks like
there's a nice spot
down here where
there's 10 clusters.
This is probably better
for our application.
We could select
even more clusters
if we want to have very
specific genre groups.
If you want a lot
of clusters it's
hard to pick the right
number from the dendrogram.
You need to use your
understanding of the problem
to pick the number of clusters.
Let's stick with 10
clusters for now,
combining what we learned
from the dendrogram
with our understanding
of the problem.
Now back in our R console we can
label each of the data points
according to what
cluster it belongs
to using the cutree function.
So let's type
clusterGroups=cutree(clusterMovies,
k=10).
Now let's figure out what
the clusters are like.
We'll use the tapply
function to compute
the percentage of movies
in each genre and cluster.
So let's type tapply, and then
give us the first argument,
movies$Action-- we'll
start the action genre--
and then clusterGroups,
and then mean.
So what does this do?
It divides our data points
into the 10 clusters
and then computes
the average value
of the action variable
for each cluster.
Remember that the
action variable
is a binary variable
with value 0 or 1.
So by computing the
average of this variable
we're computing the
percentage of movies
in that cluster that
belong in that genre.
So we can see here that
in cluster 2, about 78%
of the movies have
the action genre
label, whereas in cluster
4 none of the movies
are labeled as action movies.
Let's try this
again, but this time
let's look at the romance genre.
Here we can see that all of
the movies in clusters six
and seven are labeled as
romance movies, whereas only 4%
of the movies in cluster two
are labeled as romance movies.
We can repeat this
for each genre.
If you do you can
create a large table
to better analyze the clusters,
which I saved to a spreadsheet.
Lets take a look.
Here we have in each
column the cluster,
and in each row the genre.
I highlighted the
cells that have
a higher than average value.
So we can see here in
cluster 2, as we saw before,
that cluster 2 has a high
number of action movies.
Cluster 1 has a little bit of
everything, some animation,
children's, fantasy,
musicals, war and westerns.
So I'm calling this the
miscellaneous cluster.
Cluster 2 has a lot of
the action, adventure,
and sci-fi movies.
Cluster 3 has the crime,
mystery, thriller movies.
Cluster 4 exclusively
has drama movies.
Cluster 5, exclusively
has comedies.
Cluster 6 has a lot
of the romance movies.
Cluster 7 has movies that are
comedies and romance movies.
So I'm calling these
the romantic comedies.
Cluster 8 has the documentaries.
Cluster 9 has the movies
that are comedies and dramas,
so the dramatic comedies.
And cluster 10 has
the horror flicks.
Knowing common movie
genres, these cluster
seem to make a lot of sense.
So now, back in our
rconsole, let's see
how these clusters could be
used in a recommendation system.
Remember that Amy liked
the movie Men in Black.
Let's figure out what
cluster Men in Black is in.
We'll use the subset function
to take a subset of movies
and only look at the movies
where the Title="Men in Black
(1997)".
Close the quotes
in the parentheses.
I knew that this is the
title of Men in Black
because I looked it
up in our data set.
So it looks like Men in Black
is the 257th row in our data.
So which cluster did
the 257th movie go into?
We can figure this out by
typing clusterGroupsclusterGroups[257].
It looks like Men in
Black went into cluster 2.
That make sense
since we just saw
that cluster 2 is the action,
adventure, sci-fi cluster.
So let's create a new
data set with just
the movies from cluster two.
We'll call it cluster two,
and use the subset function
to take a subset of
movies only taking
the observations for which
clusterGroups is equal to 2.
Let's look at the first
10 titles in this cluster.
We can do this by typing
cluster2$Titlecluster2$Title[1:10].
So it looks like good
movies to recommend to Amy,
according to our
clustering algorithm,
would be movies like Apollo
13 and Jurassic Park.
In this video we
saw how clustering
can be applied to create a
movie recommendation system.
In the next video,
we'll conclude
by learning who ended up winning
the million dollar Netflix
prize.